fears of a global slowdown fueling the
biggest rally in Treasury since 2009 how
long can this continue I think that if
you look at other parts of the world
Treasuries are actually still attractive
you go over to Europe and look at Spain
and Italy they were trading at 22
two-point-three percent then you look at
the UK which is below the United States
France is about one in an eighth percent
for the 10 year in Germany is 75 76
basis points then Japan is 50 basis
points so that's crazy it is well it is
but for investors anyway for as an
investment it's more of tail risk
insurance that's what people buying
Treasuries for and they're working
treasures have actually been
phenomenally let's tell you that
deflation could be on the horizon yeah
absolutely certainly the realm of
possibilities today yes but deflation is
in Europe the eurozone is certainly
struggling with that the ECB is is inept
on what they're trying to do in regard
to ginning up inflation there but what
we're suggesting is that perhaps you
don't want to be in the sovereign debt
market overseas and that that's
extremely bubblicious being that we're
we can go anywhere equities would be the
place to be over the next 12 to 24
months we believe that you can get
pretty darn good return there of seventy
percent but you know look the economy
the United States is doing very well
okay the eurozone is not where it's
really struggling there as well as the
emerging markets are decelerating their
growth but earnings which is really the
driver and economic growth on in the
United States which is really the driver
of the equity markets here will continue
to move forward as you were suggesting
let me just note the 10-year note just
finished down basically for basis points
from where it was yesterday so we had a
wild ride but it wasn't that bad and to
put all this in perspective the S&P 500
to see a day as bad as this one you have
to go all the way back to monday Monday
the drop in the SP was twice what it was
today on the clothes as a matter of fact
friday was worse Thursday was worse
wednesday works rally back but i think
just the volatility that we saw was
pretty extraordinary we have not seen
such wild gyrations in the market like
this
and he had some time to get a formerly
srt-10 to downgrade the United States
that's when we had the ball to notice
every time the Federal Reserve pairs
back their liquidity program you get
this volatility the the Federal Reserve
is applied a sedative to the market with
the QE their pairing that back they
signaled that they will raise rates I
know yes but we knew that the last
several times as well and the markets
have went into this thing you got it got
to go through it it's like you go to the
dentist it numbs you right when the when
the novocaine wears off it hurts but you
don't keep going back and you don't keep
getting more novocaine that's what we've
been doing sooner or later you just got
to get over the toothache and you'll
feel fine it that is so well put